a function f of X is plotted below
highlight an interval where f of X is
less than zero so f of X which is really
being plotted on the vertical axis right
over here X is the horizontal axis f of
X being less than zero really means that
the graph is below the x-axis so the
graph the function is negative in this
interval right over here and this
interval over here so I could put this
anywhere right over here or I could
stick it anywhere right over here let me
stick it right over here there we go got
it right let's do a couple more so the
function is plotted below highlight an
interval where f of X is greater than
zero so I could do this area right over
here where the function is above the
x-axis or I could do this area right
over here where the function is goes way
above the XS while it even goes off the
off the page so let's stick it let's
stick it right over here let's do one
more so highlight an interval where f of
X is greater than zero once again I can
do this region right over here where the
function is a below us above the x-axis
or over here where it's above the x-axis
I'll do it here just for fun there we go